[Music]
supporter
oh yes yes yes which one do you think
this is
whoever chose this new me well i'd say
right uh
i think i have this as joey here okay
it's mine oh okay okay okay this one
this one could have gone either way
yeah you know what's funny is that this
is one of
this is one of three that i've read
before yeah yeah i was going to put it
in until gantt sent me his list
dude it's a classic it's like one of the
top rated it's one of
i think it's one of the most famous
dojinshi's like long-formed
inches of all time yeah i see one
and for good [ __ ] reason like it's
art is great story's great
all this great story is great
so essentially how this story starts is
there's just a guy who doesn't have a
job chilling on a bench
and then succubus come up to him uh kind
of like a you know like a hot singles in
your area yeah yeah
but i already have to come up to him
they're like hey uh do you want a job
helping us suck your buses
and he's like oh i don't know what that
is but okay sure
so to give a bit more context so this
world has like
has like sakibai or sakubas have
integrated into the human society
so like they're not this mythical
creature anymore
so like a lot of most of the population
of the world
has some succubus blood in it right
that's right and the science is
that the more succubus blood that's in a
guy
the less tasty their
semen is fluids their fluids are don't
come on
youtube okay okay i'm sorry i'm sorry
and of course
our main guy here is one of
like 90 like one of the 0.1 percent of
the population
less of left that is just your human
that is just pure human blood
right pure no succubus blood in this
family tree
and of course the job he is given is
to basically just like provide an all
you can eat buffet
that's the best way i can provide one
man
one man versus the world
i i mean i like this one it was very
good how can you not like this is one of
the like least offensive ones like what
guy wouldn't want this yeah just
literally just you just a piece of meat
you know just yeah yeah i'm just
one one one thing that like because this
artist i feel
is probably like the best artist when it
comes to drawing [ __ ] scenes i mean
this doge this dojinshi in general is
just 90 [ __ ] right
i think there's like one sex scene in it
and it lasts like two three pages or
something
right it's it's mostly mostly yeah
yeah yeah so clearly we know what this
artist likes
this is like it's like literally the
[ __ ] you wish you were given
like if i could give this manga a
summary it's pretty much that
uh i mean yeah i mean what what is not
to like about this the
i like i said like the god tier art
positions are fantastic
yeah yeah fantastic